je vous dire ce que dit jean messia sur
les amis je vous dire ce que vous dites
comme ça vous allez pouvoir débattre
tous les deux vous dit marine le pen je
ne lutte pas contre l'islam qui est une
religion mais contre l'islamisme qui est
une une idéologie jean messi a dit
l'islam n'est pas n'est pas de lui même
compatible avec la république
alors jean missia
vous êtes
beaucoup plus radical que marine le pen
d'abord je tiens à dire que j'ai pas
j'ai pas changé d'avis que je pensais en
2017 c'est qu'on attendait une décision
d'une des ens des plus grandes instances
de l'islam sunnite qui condamne les
djihadistes qui les ait ce communicant
quelque sorte ça n'a pas eu lieu puisque
ces gens là sont toujours considérés
comme des musulmans par notamment al
azhar donc effectivement à partir de là
il faut quand même considérer le réel et
changez pas changé d'avis mais s'il réel
ne vous donne pas satisfaction va vous
changer votre idée sur le réel ça c'est
la première chose la deuxième chose
c'est que
marine le pen vous nous dites que
l'islam est compatible avec la
république vous avez dit citoyen tu
d'accord mais vous avez donné pendant
des années tutoyait que tu nous dis que
lille
jeudi à éviter de faire défaut pour une
future es tu nous dis que tu nous dis
que l'islam est compatible avec la
république mais j'ai une question simple
à te poser ce soir est ce que tu as lu
le coran
non mais je non et je veux te dire je me
moque totalement de savoir la mairie
mais ça ne regarde pas parce que moi je
suis dans un je vais j'ai vocation est
la présidente d'un pays laïc figure toi
donc je n'ai pas à m'intéresser ni à
savoir comment ça se passe ni à financer
une religion ni à l'organiser n'y a rien
été servis l'islam et moi je suis la
vente de l'islam non mais moi je suis là
pour te protéger les dames c'est pas le
cas de la république non mais moi j'en
pardon mais j'ai tu as dit l'islam et
l'islamisme c'est la même chose comme
eric zemmour d'ailleurs j'ai même allé
plus loin des 10 5 millions de musulmans
de votre fiche est ce c'est à dire
l'intégralité des musulmans de france de
langeais à 10 or c'est une erreur non
non non non c'est vrai j'ai pas dit ça
c'est pas grave mais non efficaces on
met sur son sol ce qui est cohérent avec
la phrase de précédentes d'ailleurs moi
clairement je suis en désaccord avec
cela mais chut je vais même plus loin
que d'être en désaccord c'est quand on
fait de la politique jean il faille il
faut apporter des solutions si tu dis
comme eric zemmour l'islam et
l'islamisme c'est la même chose et donc
en réalité il faut que les musulmans
renonce à la pratique de l'islam alors
je te demande quelles sont vos solutions
politiques vous proposez quoi parce que
moi je suis allé voir le programme
dernier mot sur l'islam honnêtement ces
piteux il ya six petits points ça fait
un quart de page sur 70 pages du
programme donc je me dis faire de
l'islam le coeur de son projet politique
pour sortir un truc comme ça alors je
dis c'est pas sérieux vous allez c'est
vraiment ça c'est vraiment vous avez sur
ta vie c'est le programme de voilà donc
interdire le voile islamique au caire
interdit la construction de mosquées
imposante d'accord bon ok enfin il ya
six points alors moi je veux dire je
n'en entends parler que de ça de la part
d'eric zemmour et j'ai un programme qui
est dérisoire c'est à dire sur u10 l'amt
un catalogue enflammé ce que je veux
dire c'est que si vous considérez que
l'islam est un danger pour le pays alors
quelles sont vos propositions fermer les
mosquées expulser les musulmans retirer
la nationalité aux musulmans français
c'est quoi vos solutions politiques moi
je veux dire nous on a travaillé gens
nous on n'a pas fait ça d'accord on a
fait un vrai travail un travail sérieux
et un travail sérieux c'est autre chose
vois tu tu vois on a fait un projet de
loi à référendum sur l'immigration voilà
le référendum sur l'immigration c'est un
projet de loi il est rédigé où est le
vôtre parce que vous voulez faire un
référendum je n'ai rien vu je n'ai pas
vu de projet de loi on a fait un projet
de loi contre liste de lutte contre
l'islamisme le projet de loi est rédigée
il ya plus qu elle voté ces clés en main
donc je pense qu'il faut être un peu
sérieux avec ses sujets et arrêter de
faire plaisir encore une fois à des gens
qui que vous le je pense induisait en
erreur donc ni islam est une religion la
liberté religieuse en france oblige à
laisser les musulmans pouvoir exercer
leur foi l'islamisme c'est une idéologie
totalitaire et n il faut la combattre
avec la dernière des fermetés partout
elle est partout elle se cache partout
elle est financée par tous elle recrute
ce faux cette idéologie totalitaire qui
va à l'encontre de notre constitution
elle il faut évidemment la coumarine
comment tu expliques que le mot ici
hamid n'existe pas en arabe c'est un
artefact sémantique a été créé pour
dédouaner l'islam de sa frange
intégristes d'ailleurs c'est un effort
qu'on consent pour aucune autre religion
les juifs intégristes ont dit pas que
c'est des judaïste les chrétiens
intégristes ont dit pas que c'est des
christianiste ont dit des chrétiens
intégristes donc l'islam c'est l'islam
c'est le coran d'ailleurs je vais te
faire lecture puisque tu ne connais pas
l'islam je vais te faire lecture d'un
verset du coran et en assistant comme ça
mais je vais te les épargnants ne pas
faire de la théologie c'est à
dire que dans ce large et sur le bâti
bhl avec la république tu parles de
l'islam donc si tu connais pas l'islam
tu peux pas savoir s'il est compatible
avec la république ou pas enel l'asie
n'a qu'a fait lober hayat nassau fans au
salon du nord qu'elle a menée
je te traduit certes ceux qui ne croient
pas à nos au coran nous les brûlerons
bientôt dans le feu chaque fois que leur
peau auront été consumés nous leur
donnerons d'autres peaux en échange afin
qu'ils goûtent aux châtiments je pense
assez de l'islam ou de lys la grc de
l'islam ou lis les gens tu n'es pas avec
moi ma question lorsque ça c'est de lys
l'argentier n'est pas sérieux tu n'es
pas sérieux parce que tu sais
pertinemment qu'il ya toute une série de
pays musulmans qui lutte contre
l'islamisme et us à faire des
différences lutte contre la menace d'al
islam intégré en lui à cent miles
islamiste n'existe man u contre l'islam
et islamisme c'est un confort que qu'on
a créé d'ailleurs parlé d'islam et
l'ailleurs est un continuum marien des
pays qui lutte contre l'islamisme c'est
l'égypte bon justement est ce que
federer la parole 11 ans est un pays que
je connais très bien la wii a bien dit
qu'est ce que fait l'egypte révèlent-ils
et l'egypte fait quelque chose il est
justement le sait l'egypte fait quelque
chose de traite de très bien c'est que
justement elle empêche qu'on applique
l'islam dans son intégralité au sein de
la société et donc elle freine
l'application de l'islam pour rendre sa
pratique d'accord compatible avec ce
qu'est la société égyptienne ce que
d'ailleurs les autorités les élites
françaises ne font pas au passage c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on assiste à
l'islamisation de notre pays donc si
vous si tu veux si tu proclames il ya
quelque chose de très incohérent dans
ton projet parce que tu nous aussi tu
nous dis que l'islam est compatible avec
la république dans ce cas là le voile
est compatible avec la république le
halal est compatible avec la république
les horaires dans les piscines pour les
hommes et chez les femmes sont
compatibles avec la république y'a pas
de problème en fait mais tu es est ce
que je vois la marine est ce que l'on
voit les il sort le pays les islamistes
mais enfin jean ne fait pas semblant de
pas comprendre qu'il sait très bien que
dans les pays et une position à
m'élancer tout cohérent c'est toi qui
est à marine le pen sur ce qui rendait
les exemples que nos dirigeants et si je
vous répondrai simplement les pays
musulmans qui luttent contre l'islam et
jean que ce qu'ils ont fait tu vois
quand ils ont réussi à à à gagner contre
l'islamisme la première chose qu'ils ont
fait c'est retirer le voile aux femmes
justement c'est ce que les islamistes
ont fait à chaque fois qu'ils ont gagné
souvent par la terreur par la peur et
par la guerre c'est précisément la
première accepté de voiler les femmes
qui se sont dit qu'ils avaient cueilli
musulmans dans lequel justement il était
interdit d'avoir de séparer les femmes
des hommes parce que c'était considéré
comme en réalité une idéologique est une
idéologie la miss en turquie kamal
attaturk à importer la laïcité
occidental pour l'appliquer par la
dictature à une société turque qui par
essence est musulmane d'ailleurs quand
atatürk partie la société turque est en
train de revenir temporairement c'est ce
que tu préfères tu sais ce que tu
devrais faire tu devrais venir à mayotte
mayotte qui votent à 45% pour moi tu vas
et bien à mayotte 95% des habits
français sont musulmans et il n'y a pas
une once d'islamisme tu veux je te dis
c'est à dire qu'il n'y a pas toutes ces
revendications
toutes ces séparations toutes ces
violations de la constitution toute
cette inégalité entre les hommes et les
femmes il n'y a pas tout ça donc je suis
désolé de te dire que les harkis que
nous avons évidemment accueilli français
qui ont choisi la france est bien cela
n'était pas des islamistes ils étaient
des musulmans ils n'ont posé aucun
problème
oui mais est d'ailleurs si on leur avait
confié l'organisation d'ailleurs de
l'islam on n'en serait peut-être pas là
parce que les islamistes aurait pas mis
la main sur un certain nombre de
structures avec c'est vrai la
complaisance de beaucoup de dirigeants
politiques qui par accommodements
raisonnables ou par peur de s'attaquer à
cette idéologie ont fermé les yeux donc
je veux dire ce que je pense j'en sais
qu'il faudrait travailler voilà tu vois
je pense qu'il faudrait vous travailler
parce que la réalité ne travaillez pas
vous fait plaisir en l'ensemble des
anathèmes qui peuvent blesser départ
de confession musulmane pour moi je dois
le dire senales et ça ne sert à rien moi
te le dire parce que ça réglera pas le
problème moi tu vois mon projet d'eau
avenue du référendum réglera le procès
mon projet go contre l'islamisme réglera
le problème tout encore une fois est
rédigé il n'y a plus qu'à faire voter au
référendum et à faire voter la loi et
alors nous règlerons les difficultés
jean michel2 de des français m confronté
à cette idéologie marc islamistes
laissons d'alain sondage ifop qui date
de 2010 9 essais s'est pas rangé depuis
dit que 61% des français disent que
l'islam est incompatible avec les
valeurs de la société française est ce
que tu proposes à turin et le supprimer
la verdure justement et de l'autre côté
tu as près des deux tiers des jeunes
musulmans qui prétendent que lilloise
les lois de l'islam sont supérieurs à
ceux de la république donc en réalité je
veux savoir qui tu parles parce que les
français sont enfin d'accord avec toi et
même les musulmans sont pas d'accord
avec toi je t'ai dire sur un coup de fer
tu comptes réécrivent blendecques ce
sacré jean est ce que tu contraire non
gens je compte faire voter ce projet de
loi y'a quoi d'autres projets de l'eau
marine le pen c'est un petit tournoi
c'est un projet de loi qui vise à lutter
contre l'idéologie islamiste partout où
elle est partout où elle apparaît
partout où elle se répand pour protéger
encore une fois les français du
développement de ses activités au logis
de cette idéologie à interdire le voile
totalitaire oui je veut interdire le
voile parce que leur voilier d'un mini
vraiment clichés liste mais que dois-je
faire gens je dois rejet mais qu'est ce
que je veux mais je te dire moi je vais
te faire comprendre je vais te faire
comprendre l'humanité que je te dise je
vais faire comprendre la différence
entre lutter contre l'immigration et
lutter contre les immigrés ce que vous
voulez faire je vais te faire comprendre
la différence entre lutter contre
l'islamisme et s'attaquer à des jeunes
filles qui devaient pas avoir plus de 15
ans et qui voulait faire une photo avec
moi qu'est ce que tu aurais fait quoi si
nous cessons voix
j'en ai pas pris j'aurais pas pris un
seul fille avec elle et là
c'est moi
merci
je voulais enchaîner eric zemmour a
tweeté cette photo de vous marine le pen
avec cette jeune fille voilée juste jean
bessière coq est ce que vous auriez fait
quoi vous parce que c'est pas je
m'attend je leur ai dit quoi bein je
n'aurais pas pris de cette furie des
mois la jeune fille aurait pas pris
c'est fait avec un volant droite
tchèques qui on veut vous n'avez jamais
fait de celle fille avec une jeune femme
voilée on a le droit de pas ce que vous
en avez déjà fait un nom on vous a déjà
demandé hommage à demander et à zi qua
non pourquoi mais pourquoi devrais je
pense qu'on lutte parce qu'il avait été
nommé
d'histoire dit non je veux croire l'atsa
dans la conférence de presse justement
qui présentait ton proton projet de loi
de lutte contre le séparatisme
j'ai lu donc dans les éléments de
langage de ta communication prennent
représentée par monsieur garraud député
en parlant du voile d'interdire toute
manifestation publique d'une idéologie
qui constitue par elles mêmes un trouble
grave à l'ordre public c'est déjà le cas
par exemple du nazisme met donc en fait
le rassemblement national compare les
tenues islamiques mais nos voiles comme
les toulousains salafistes ils sont
l'interdire sur la même genre gens du
nazi il faudra je comprends pas
qu'aujourd'hui marine le pen nous
explique qu'elle lutte contre l'islam
intégriste et qu'elle va interdire le
voile en prenant des photos avec ce
qu'elle va interdire gens je vais
t'expliquer tu veux se disent je vais
t'expliquer souhaité expliquer la
différence qu'il ya entre lutter contre
des gens et lutter contre un phénomène
dont l'idéologie islamiste encore une
fois j'ai bossé non mais vous devriez le
faire mais moi je m'attaque pas aux gens
et je vais même te dire que j'ai
toujours ma vie sans doute ma vie et moi
toute ma vie j'ai suivi c'était ce
qu'est ce qu'ils vont me tuer je te
rassure au sol ça travaille pas ou
abbaoui bas mais peut-être que ce trail
pas mais moi j'ai des textes qui sont
préparés et vous nous avez un espèce de
torchon et ses études sous et donc c'est
pas bien c'est
ici
[Musique]
on
l'a tous eu tous ceux qui nous regardent
au secret en salle des professeurs jean
jaurès paris quelque chose quand jésus
avocat
j'étais commis d'office pour défendre
des gens et j'ai défendu des clandestins
il y avait des gens sont tués si si
c'est d'avoir des gens comme toi qui
disais mais comment vous êtes contre eux
étaient déjà en ligne et vous êtes
contre l'immigration clandestine et vous
défendez des clandestins et bien oui
parce que je pense que même s'il était
clandestins ils avaient le droit d'être
défendu par un avocat mais
accessoirement à bonn avocat et donc je
les fais et il y avait des gens pour me
le reprocher gens des gens qui comme toi
ne savent pas faire la différence était
et ce sens qu'ils avaient enfreint les
lois marine mais pas c'est pas les
choses la c1 c'est un c'est un symbole
politique pour l'instant il n'est pas et
vous voulez si tu n'as que j'allais
courir ce genre si jamais ça si tu n'as
pas le même site la page d'affronter une
personne tu auras pas le courage
d'affronter la masse jamais ça alors je
me suis ajusté soit le courage
d'affronter une gamine de 15 ans tu n'as
pas le courage de le faire c'est ça que
tu n'as pas le courage de refuser donc
demain tu l'auras pas inventer toutes
les vaut tous les voiles et toutes les
manifestations de l'islam radical et
surtout si tu prétends que l'islam est
compatible avec la république faut que
tu sois cohérente honnêtement je trouve
c'est quoi je serais je trouve que c'est
très intéressant ce débat parce que ça
révèle quand même une partie du projet
d'eric zemmour il partie de sa brutalité
pas du tout une partie sa dureté qui est
juste inutile l'utilité c'est encore une
fois faire des lois et les verra
appliquer s'attaquer à des personnes
s'attaquent à des gamines marine le pen
les humilier orient disait marine le pen
on jurerait pas de photo avec toi parce
que parce que je suis contre le
terrorisme devrait juste être
contre le voile c'est john finney keller
très sympathique a voulu faire à un self
eric vous imaginons demain vous êtes
présidente de la république elle ne veut
pas enlever le voile j'avais fait un
voilà vous avez vous vous étiez bien
avec elle elle vous avez david et vous
l'avez dit voilà c'est vrai vous avez
envie d'aller la douane oui mais ça veut
dire que voulez vous la renvoyez mais
elles n'ont à l'oral mais cette jeune
fille allait france oui c'est simple il
vous fait quoi et bien alors à une
amende à mende les choses tous les jours
avoir une amende oui elle ne respecte
les voyageurs qu'elle vous dérange pas
elle ne respecte mais si ça me dérange
c'est le problème j'ai ouï dire monsieur
nouna c'est qu'en réalité il ya 20 ans y
avait pas de problème de voile
jamais personne n'en portait pourtant il
y avait déjà des musulmans 1 il y avait
déjà des gens qui étaient venus dans
notre pays personne aucune femme ne
portait le voile mais les forces à l'itc
que des islamistes ils ont réussi à
convaincre ou à faire pression dans des
quartiers et beaucoup de français
d'ailleurs musulmans vivent sous cette
pression là la pression leurs proches
là le fait de dire mais ta femme si elle
n'est pas voilée c'est que en réalité
elle n'est pas pudique d'affilée que ces
dames et toute cette pression qui s'est
développée elle s'est développée parce
qu'encore une fois on n'a pas posé la
ligne la ligne c'est ça c'est un
uniforme islamistes et accessoirement
c'est un acte de soumission des femmes
moi je suis encore une fois
fondamentalement opposés mais je ne me
pose encore une fois par la loi mais
92 ne pourrait pas le faire vous rendez
compte de la deûle à de la vie de cette
jeune fille si besoin vous êtes
présidente et qu'elle est elle
desservirait ne savait rien les jours
elle va prendre les violences avaient
rien peut-être sera t-elle libéré vous
ne savez pas ce qu'il ya derrière ce
voile ou non sa mère j'ai reçu pour ce
soit celle sur le taux qui était très
heureuse de porter le voile c'était leur
choix certainement oui et bien
certainement mais en a beaucoup d'autres
pour lequel c'est pas le choix et moi ce
que je dis c'est que beaucoup ont
utilisé ce voile en réalité pour
démontrer qu'ils étaient en quelque
sorte visuellement propriétaire de ce
territoire deuxièmement je pense que
c'est en plus très contraire à la
laïcité parce que la laïcité c'est quoi
la laïcité ce site se dire on se croise
en fait on échange des biens je ne sais
pas ce que vous êtes là qui je ne sais
pas quelle religion je ne sais pas de
quelle religion vous êtes là kidman ya
aussi une armée équipe personne kenyan
parce que je crois qu'encore une fois le
ventre c'est un uniforme islamistes
c'est une idéologie islamistes qui
oblige à porter mais deux ans plus si
vous voulez je pense que ça renferment
ces jeunes filles en réalité on voit
même plus une jeune fille d'ailleurs
leur élection de jean bessière et très
révélatrice on voit plus de jeunes
filles on voit une musulmane et ça c'est
vraiment pas mais à mon avis une
marine je te poser une question et
choses positives pour l 90 90 % des
femmes qui sont dans le monde arabo
musulman sont vous allez donc ça veut
dire que dans le monde arabo-musulman 90
% des femmes sont des islamistes d'après
toi non ça n'est pas vrai ce que tu dis
n'est pas masqué c'est vrai je connais
très bien le monde arabo musulman ce que
tu dis ce que tu dit maintenant tu vas
dans des pneus mais je suis allé au 6
avril donc là vu de ses propres yeux et
udine et je dirai juste je dirais pas
pour aller dans ton sens qu'en réalité
il n'ya aucune religion qui par elle
même compatible avec la république
française les les religions dont nous
avons obtenu la compatibilité c'est
parce que la république les a forcés à
se rendre compatible c'est le cas du
judaïsme avec napoléon c'est le cas
aussi du catholicisme qui pourtant la
religion française qui a fait la france
à la fin du 19e siècle décret ferry pour
laïcisé la société a procédé à la
fermeture de centaines de congrégations
religieuses ils ont viré des milliers de
religieux et donc l'islam est
aujourd'hui je l'aimais chargeant du don
et c'est un pas dit ce que vous avez
fait ça alors justement marine ne pas
nous aussi on va et josy géant l'islam
ce qu'on a exigé aux trolls des autres
religions c'est à dire c'est quoi la
discrétion religieuse c'est à dire
l'absence de construction l'interdiction
la fin de construction de mosquées
cathédrales on va exiger des gens ils
s'assimilent à la france voilà c'est ça
assène quelle forme non mais d'accord
mais je sens mais ça ça prend quelques
secondes est d'accord déjà c'est pas de
mosquées cathédrales tous les racoins
achats mais c'est très faible par
rapport aux jours de la violence de
votre discours quand même pas pas du
tout je crois que c'est l'atmosphère ces
faibles comme les yeux discours jeudi il
n'est pas violent puisque notre du
cheveu de discourir rejoint par 61% des
français
c'est-à-dire la 61 % des français
approuvent l'idée que l'islam n'est pas
de lui-même compatible avec la
république et que même ça va jusqu'à 80%
mais on dira que l'islam posant à la
laïcité donc les gens c'est très bien je
sais très bien que beaucoup français
précisément avec des discours comme ceux
là qui mélange la religion et
l'idéologie de dignitaires pro base
électorale d'autres impôts bas ils sont
d'accord avec moi ce que je vois c'est
que vous tenez un peu moins un propos
politique et qu'en réalité derrière il
n'y a rien il n'y a aucune proposition
quand on dit 5 millions de musulmans
devraient être fichés sg en visite à
rien il ya une proposition j'ai pas dis
seigneur moi j'ai dit j'ai dit qu'il
faut interdire les frères musulmans il
faut interdire les congas c'est ça nous
lisons aussi j'en
mets cm mais c'est ça que je quelques
jours a jugé que c'est dû à caution mais
alors si c'est quoi fait nos
connaissances multiples avec la
république il faudra un intérieur mafia
et marc messier marina prises avec la
république il faut interdire l'islam il
faut assainir coin qui est interdire la
pratique intégrale de l'islam ce que des
sociétés à office la mise mais donc il
n'y a pas d'histoire au bizet n'existe
pas parce que je me sens mais juste
l'islam intelligent mais ça aujourd'hui
la seule religion qui pose problème à la
france visibilité en termes de
revendication identitaire saisir ce
parti s'est séparé le bouddhisme voilà
six ans que les gens messia vous avez
été aura son moment nationale pendant
des années est ce que vous trouvez que
le discours de marine le pen s'est
assouplie oui ce sujet je je je pense
qu'il ne qu'il sait qu'il s'est assoupli
il ya eu une série de niveaux palapa pas
seulement là dessus d'ailleurs je pense
qu'ils allaient céder quelques années en
07 jeudi j'ai la même chose sur l'islam
à redon en 2017 je disais la même chose
ait eu était d'accord à en 2015 par en
2016 allumée en 2010 et 2000 quand même
en deux et a fait la campagne comme un
gg oui c'est même sahara et de la
campagne
souviens-toi que tu as campagne n'était
pas faite sur l'identité l'immigration
c'est ça d'ailleurs qui t'a coûté très
cher parce que tu as choisie avec les
conseils de fleurs au philippot de faire
une campagne sur des questions
monétaires que personne ne comprenait
donc effectivement cette question là
n'était pas frontalement posée aux
français nous nous disons et d'ailleurs
c'est ce que je te rends tu as dit en
exergue gâteau j'en mets chargeant mais
si tu tenais ce propos de effectivement
l'immigration l'islam etc depuis des
années et au moment où toute la société
se convertit à ce pourquoi des
générations de militants d'adhérents des
lecteurs de sympathisants se sont battus
tu y renonce mais je
sais pour rama et où es tu et pour
continuer à lamerat moi tu joues je me
retirer mais géant en panne sur les gens
autre problématique on fêta parce que je
parte du pouvoir d'achat et ça vous
dérange et face à la méprise on
travaillait chez nous de parler du
pouvoir d'achat oui effectivement je
parle aussi du pouvoir les gens parlent
on dit parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya une
urgence sociale auxquelles il faut
répondre je sais que vous considérez pas
du tout comme ça aussi la question moi
je trouve la question c'est que nous
sommes les seuls à parler de la france à
la france donc si nous cessons de parler
de la france à la france et que nous
parlerait il t'a pas échappé que les
gens qui arrivent au rassemblant
rationnels ils rejoignent pas leur
assemblée nationale sur le réchauffement
climatique ou sa politique des sports
d'accord il y aura autant le
rassemblement national sur la
problématique identitaire j'en ai déjà
existant sur les sages dans le sérieux
qu'ils vont jouer avec ça c'est ici pas
seulement ici j'ai seulement deux
minutes merci s'il ne vient pas seul
pays majoritairement s'armer passage en
messieurs marine le pen éditions dc 17,2
des services publics du système avec nos
missions sociales c'est sur brit air est
une c'est pas la productivité jugée en
messieurs vous avez dit un truc
intéressant ya les photos vous avez dit
cette photo marine le pen ne l'aurais
jamais fait et en 2017 on domine
acariens et hassen il ya six sept ans
l'europe à fait vrai ah oui habana
l'aurait refusée mais je pense je pense
que je n'aurai pas publiés vous l'aurez
refuser ces fonds loin si ce n'est pas
du tout mais encore une fois je répète
moi je sais pas j'ai l'impression que en
2017 quand tu faisais la campagne avec
moi il ya une grande émission sur tf1 on
m'a posé la question est ce que l'islam
est compatible et que la vie me j'ai
répondu oui oui mais c'était dans la
salle de tak en août une marine tu n'es
pas parti en vrille magnien ça ne t'a
pas choqué à ce qu'a laissé faire parler
encore dit me gratte tu vas parler à
l'époque tu parlais encore d'immigration
d'identité française que tu plaçait au
pinacle de temps suffisamment à dire en
avril aujourd'hui c'est plus le cas tu
viens de médiane en 2017 il
parle d'identité tu ne parles plus
d'islamisation tu ne seras plus de grand
remplacement tout ça tu l'a rejeté par
les grands à 6 en 2011 de la cité et du
parler du grand remplacement du peuple
français jean messi a aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qui fait que vous êtes plus eric
zemmour que marine le pen je veux dire
que en fait un programme un projet
présidentiel il ya évidemment ça attaque
tout les toutes les problématiques
économiques sociales écologiques
agricole éducative la question n'est pas
là c'est pas parce que nous parlons
prioritairement de l'immigration de
derry de l'islamisation du pays que de
ne parlons pas d'autre chose dans chaque
programme présidentiel il faut qu'il y
ait une première priorité et les autres
bien sûr sont toujours présentes marine
le pen a décidé de faire campagne sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat exactement
comme jean luc mélenchon sans parler du
reste voilà nous nous parlons de
l'immigration de la menace existentielle
historique qui pèse sur la france pour
une raison très simple c'est que vous
savez le pouvoir d'achat vous pouvez le
restaurer en quelques mois et de mesures
bien ciblées que nous avons en projet
même l'économie vous pouvez la redresser
en quelques mois ou quelques années mais
la perte d'identité d'un pays vous
mettez parfois des siècles à la
récupérer rappelez-vous du peuple
d'israël chassé de chez lui il ya 2000
ans il a mis deux mille ans pour
récupérer sa terre et effectivement les
français aujourd'hui ne veulent pas être
le peuple errant qui une fois qu'il
n'est plus chez lui elle va passer sa
vie à a retrouvé son pays vous savez moi
mes ancêtres ont déjà perdu un pays ne
tient pas en perdre un deuxième champ
pardon mais pardon mais honnêtement tu
n'es pas de bonne foi parce que j'ai
commencé mon monde ma campagne et tu le
sais par ce référendum je les présentais
j'ai fait une conférence de presse gelée
rédigeait sallèles gelé travailler et
encore une fois vous n'avez s'inverser
impasse allez vous m'expliquez vous
allez devoir non parlons pas le problème
c'est que vous ne faites que par les non
mais que et que quand on voit encore une
fois la place que prend les sujets que
vous considérez comme prioritaires dans
le projet c'est pas sérieux donc moi je
jeu j'ai toujours évoquée évidemment le
problème de l'immigration j'ai travaillé
je propose un projet clé en main en
français il s'exprime mon dessus d'où
sera ainsi fait pour reprendre la main
la maîtrise sur un phénomène qui est un
phénomène
extrêmement on le sait et je le dis
depuis bien longtemps problématique et
uccle et vu les phares les du crime et
henri têtu crédibilité pour ne pas lui
le projet de maastricht crois qu'il se
dire sur un lit sur l'immigration mais
tu attends ils ont lu mast mais tu as
tort ils ont lu la constitution
européenne ils l'ont lu ils ont beau tu
es seul tu sais j'en fait existe en ciel
ils ont pas nos clients tu considère
donc tu considères que les français sont
idiots lassant et que comme ils sont
idiots l'arrivée six points comme ça
parce que ça leur va bien de la
boudeuse merci merci merci
et surveiller
pour pas qu'on se quitte sur ça
j'aimerais qu'on met une photo qui date
un peu de vous deux voilà vous regardez
vous étiez tous les deux en soirée moi
je crois une magnifique photo voilà
voilà ça vous rappelle pas des bons
souvenirs ça à marine
vous le regrettez vous le regrettez non
non mais moi j'ai encore une fois je
n'ai aucun regret voilà mon existence je
n'ai pas de regret les gens partent ils
partent en général c'est eux qui
regrette j'ai heureusement siens avec je
dois être le pari périence je dois être
le premier à le paraguay je serais
heureux dans un bien dans ma nouvelle
vie d'accord dans votre nouvelle maison
nous voilà la reconquête oui
très bien
merci nous les avons nos trucs et d'y
aller non bon vent et bonne mer
sans rancune en bonne mère merci à 2027
en tout cas yannick jadot va nous
rejoindre dans un instant vers sigean
des siens
2010 est une année dit moi je croyais
que tu seras pas tu seras encore
candidate en 2001 dit moi je croyais que
c'était extrêmement urgent là le combat
pour la revanche sera entre la situation
était dramatique et settat et vous êtes
déjà vous en train de vous procurer en
2025 urgente que ton maintien aux
politiques marine donc tu seras toujours
là en 2027 merci jean bessière merci
merci d'avoir été là marine le pen c'est
un peu mesquin c'est bon c'est un peu
mesquin si tu ne te ressemble pas les
gens allez merci en tout cas à vous deux
vous serez l'an 2027 ben je me
représenterai pour un deuxième mandat
ouais c'était un piège vraiment
[Applaudissements]